[Music]
this year for me has been a lot it's
been a lot of good it's been a lot of
really complicated and so on behalf of
like my family and me thank you so much
for for being there she's there we're
here taylor swift's big night at the
American Music Awards the singer
seemingly taking the high road
following that Scooter Braun let's call
it a situation situation good let me
just say cheers to you and cheers to you
Taylor Swift because you now hold the
record for the most win okay in American
Music Awards history she now has 29
total she took home six tonight sure see
you girl winning every category that she
was respected in including of course
artist of the decade are we that
surprised because I'm standing next to a
big Taylor Swift stand and I know the
Swifty's go hard for her and he's a fan
voted award okay but little did she know
she was me breaking records I will say I
felt like I was waiting for that moment
where she took us took the stage to the
opportunity during one of her speeches
to address the scooter brought stuff
directly but it was a little more it was
more pointed than it was direct that
there's a difference with that I think
what she did tonight was look she took
the high road when they go low we go
high I will say um she did sort of
address it that at the very beginning of
her medley when she I'm just gonna let
it play out for you guys the man right
here
[Music]
okay can we first talk about the fact
that every single album is printed the
name of the album printed on the shirt
on the back it says fearless I think
this was kind of her way of addressing
this situation with scooter without
really saying anything at all she let
the music do the talking and this
situation being of course Taylor claimed
that Big Machine Records was preventing
her from performing her old music yeah
and I feel like that the clothes say at
all besides the fact that she chose to
open with the man she could've chose any
song to open that medley with but the
you were talking about the clothes it
looked like almost prison garb like
prison clothes you know right with all
her I was locked up can we talk about
all the young girls that are there and I
feel like here she is wanting to sort of
fight for herself quite for other
artists fight for girls and that's what
the man is really all about is like why
are there these double standards right
and it was the way she did it I liked it
too you know put it into the performance
a little bit and she didn't sit on that
for too long because she wanted now
celebration of her whole career and I
will say we didn't know whether or not
she was gonna be performing all of her
old hits she did until tonight exactly
so unclear exactly what that means for
the future with big machine and where
they all stand and where the legalities
and the contracts and all that stand but
she did perform them tonight which i
think is a promising writing if anything
I think that's where the performance
ended the way it did too because it
ended with love or you guys she took us
on a whole journey okay yeah because all
the album's are now ingrained in this
amazing beautiful grand piano yeah and I
see right there that it's as fearless
right there of course it's the most
prominent one and red yeah but don't you
think that's very telling very telling
some of the songs that she's saying
though tonight were I mean a was an epic
performance I will say we had some of
her biggest hits she's saying a love
story right we got I knew you were
trouble we got space blank space shake
it off you know you got shake off the
haters okay with shake it off we also
had Camila Cabello Anna Halsey come on
stage and join her which is not
surprising that Camila came out there
because she was also on the reputation
tour where she's saying that every night
with her but then also having Halsey and
both of those women have been
very supportive of Taylor Swift
throughout the years and especially
throughout things with a Scooter Braun
and Scott Borchetta big machine
situation they've both been very vocal
especially ballsy for sure almost
impassioned yeah what a girl-power
moment up there absolutely and I feel
like that's what Taylor was dedicate her
speech to were those people who have
stood by her her friends her family and
her fans because she did say you know
when she won artist of the year that you
know all artists want to do is make an
impact and want their music to last you
know and she says more than anything as
complicated as this year has been she
has to think the people that have stood
by her and that's as much as she
addressed and also with her speech she
also kind of called out Halsey for her
speech and really praised her and
praised the words the Halsey had to say
she said I don't think I can top what
Halsey said yeah and I love seeing just
this friendship that we saw tonight this
really felt like a celebration a
friendship this felt like a celebration
of lover but also the past decade of
Taylor Swift music and the future of
female artists if we can may say a
little bit bigger you know and I won't
say Taylor I think you had the
performance of the night it was a really
really really smashing treat it really
was yeah what was your favorite part I
have to see the beginning the man and
the girl the young girls wear clothes
like it was amazing and then she like of
course razzle dazzle like Taylor does
with the gold fringe you know yes
classic I also think her singing I knew
you were trouble she kind of like this
fun dark twist on it I think that was
the taste of reputation - I know it's
from red yeah but that was that that
clicked that with the angry Taylor who
that is a woman scorned
yeah but I step back but it ended on a
light note that's amazing yeah but you
know Taylor's performance was not the
only thing the internet was talking
about here are some other AMA moments
that went viral
starting with Selena Gomez uh Taylor's
bestie in the audience cheering on
Taylor during the performance with her
parents Taylor's parents what I think
was so special about this two and you
see Andrea Swift right there she got
really emotional watching Taylor Swift
her daughter on stage we know that
Andrea's had quite the health battle
that she's been enduring and then she
was there and to see just that support
with Selena Gomez who was Taylor's best
friend now for what a decade it seems
like I mean just so supportive cheering
each other on the in
throughout the entire night and a bit of
a full circle moment for Selena too
because obviously and we'll get to the
performances later but she did open the
show with new singles and she had said
that Taylor and her parents were the
first people to hear it and see the
video so it's kind of amazing that
they're all there to support each other
in real life and just just see the love
there was was epic someone who maybe
wasn't showing as much support when they
were performing
[Music]
okay so this is the moment that went
viral guys this is during Camila and
Sean's performance of Santa Rita a lot
of people on the internet speculated and
try to read Jenna's mouth and they said
that she said that Camila was so always
extra oh come on I don't know if we can
but yeah so apparently the internet was
quick to think that Jenna said she's
always extra dirty look like that's what
she was saying but I did it's unclear if
she was actually talking about Camila
they could have been having a completely
different conversation that's very true
that's just me trying to play devil's
advocate you could have seen someone
else on the audience in a crazy outfit
and like she's always a yeah she did
after so she said that she was getting
text messages throughout the night so
did you shade Camila what's up with you
and Camila that's kind of went viral on
Twitter she addressed it on her
Instagram story take a look hi guys
leaving the AMAs I'm getting a lot of
text messages from people wondering if I
was shading Camila no I love her I love
her so much
I'm such a big fan of hers I don't I
don't understand what that's about but
no I love her love her love her um guys
we were bumping and grinding so hard to
senorita so crazy anyways
and to be fair later on genna's story
she posted performance of Camila with
the fire emoji say yes so maybe was
taken out of context I'm glad that she
kind of cleared the air with that so you
can't get anything past people on
Twitter like hawks went through those
like another viral moment though
actually ret cameras caught this you
guys when Billy Eilish met Billy Porter
and big shout out to Kelty night for
making this magic happen just take a
look I want you to meet Billy which you
got Billy BT Billy and then Billy later
introduced Billie Joe Armstrong of Green
Day for his performance I mean yeah a
meeting of the buildings at the 2019 of
a lot of Billy's there today and also I
thought it was funny that both Billy
Porter and Billy Eilish had those that
like white head gear gear on us or they
brought the fashion and the art to the
AMAs of course there were so many
incredible moments on the AMA stage but
there were also some moments that maybe
you did not see on TV
that's right thankfully our very own
caste Delora was there in the audience
catching all the shenanigans behind the
scenes she joining us right now cast
what did you observe give us all the tea
from inside the AMAs Danny no I'm
literally still as you can tell with the
bright lights here in Los Angeles this
is actually this was my first award show
believe it or not that I actually got to
sit inside with because as you guys
might know you know once we do the red
carpet and whatnot breather a still
working or be kind of a little exhausted
to go inside and catch all the action
but tonight I was there front and center
well maybe not front and center
definitely front and center but I was a
little bit
I'm Taylor for the biggest night here at
the AMAs and you know speaking of Taylor
I just I'm gonna start off with her
because you know I am I'm a Taylor Swift
fan I am no Katie Kraus we all know I
lead for the Jonas Brothers but I'm not
gonna lie I gained a lot of respect and
love for Taylor tonight
the way that she captivated an audience
with not only her performance but her
speeches and just her presence on stage
let me tell you that during her artists
of the decade performance that was the
first time in the entire night that all
of the audience literally all of the
audience was up on their feet granted
you know at the beginning of the show
for Selena people were standing on their
feet you know when I looked left and
right but really it was Taylor that the
whole Microsoft theater was up and it
was honest to god I had chills
throughout my body when she opened it
with the man and she was wearing you
know one of those white collared you
know I want to say like boyfriend
t-shirts almost really the significance
of opening her artists of the decade
performance with this granted a lot of
you know complications this year with
what she's dealt with personally you
know with Scooter Braun and Scott
Borchetta and the whole drama with big
machine I think that it was so
significant to start her performance
with the man and literally when I tell
you I feel like everyone in the audience
felt that significance - I'm not kidding
we all had the chills people I had I had
a group of like four guys that were
standing in front of me and they were
going wild for Taylor Swift I'm not
kidding you and I apologize if this is a
little pixelated here and you can't
really see me clearly I'm standing
outside the Microsoft theater and
there's still a lot going on and Cathy I
went around I want to ask you one thing
though did it seem like when you were
there in the audience where people
surprised that she did not take on
head-on any of that controversy or any
of that drama like what was the feeling
in that you know what I'm not gonna lie
I was sitting with a friend of mine
ironically also named Taylor who was
with me and we looked at each other and
we
were surprised that she did not address
it in her speech but at the same time it
almost was it wasn't the place because
she had said it through her art if you
if you know what I mean I mean if you
watch that performance you just you
understood the magnitude of it and kind
of a message that she was sending
especially with opening it with the man
it's almost like she didn't need to
address it everything that she wanted to
say has already been said and she kind
of took the high road and she didn't
need to you know use her big moment in
her speech to address any type of drama
yeah this was her night and she she kind
of took the high road cimoli yeah she
lasts throughout the whole night
literally you say it's her night I mean
she literally she was so empowering of
other people she was standing on her
feet throat she was one of the artists
that I actually had like a direct
eyeline site to the entire night and let
me tell you that green sparkly number
that she was wearing he's even more
sparkly in person I love it I was like I
was blinded by it but she was supporting
everyone during you know jury Selena's
performance she was literally standing
there
cheering she had arms up in the air she
was jumping up and down it was it was I
you could feel the girl power right
there girl power good night for Taylor
good night for her friends too and I
hate to cut you off short cast but we do
have a treat for everybody watching
because before Taylor was artist of the
decade she was performing at the AMAs
for the first time and each he was there
to catch her before her big debut take a
look I was really nervous about the
performance I was really nervous about
the award I was I've been nervous about
everything anything that has to do with
the award shows I'm nervous about but
it's over now and I can't believe that I
actually won that award it's amazing
it's voted for by the fans right I mean
that's what makes it very special it
makes it amazing it makes it so valid to
me you know I mean it's the most amazing
compliment when a huge amount of people
vote for an award and you end up winning
it you know it's amazing
[Music]